так цілу офісу в центрі Берліна центр
скіф на європейських та міжнародних
після джин в'їхав та шекель до денного
закиньте голову ти мене тут активно
guttural ісидору чистові відкриття у
значимого на 27 і березня по java
і на світ інститут у нічну світові та за
взяття конфлікту між Росією та
євросоюзом і ти раз патча вся з
євромайдану
то пухлий би вся через анексію крима то
вейну на сході України
сам цей чудовий матч і news відома ще
упустив ще є надзвичайно важливо
у російські політики ще краї не в краї
шлюбу я я тісну експертну оцінку того
адже буває в Росії зі словами
директор інституту його завдання у нічний
ширше за зовнішніх дітей накрив аналогія я за
годинник у холодній війні якщо я of the
battle for the sun наше завдання я у
велике в тому навчально у кого про грунтову
ну і брила куди свіжого щось на старі
врізних краї носку дно і Європи
процеси на ремені з usb листя економіки
і політикою це означає на ближчу ніш
просто з постригу за крим важливі вам
ви іклом буде донести результати наших
до слідів до політики в засоби в
масової інформації це істоти і знає
і для тіла ефективніший формат та інше
спрацювати з tesla читку і відразу ввела
короткому кляп він пошле лящ аватарами
тенкан перегляду закинула вас пором за
Давид крокет усереднити до інституту
приурочені вернісаж рубає англійської
фотографа марка навела на тому ж ті
вигаданих переселенців в Україні на і
whelan і поки це ще конфлікт надходило
знака з поля зору європейських ЗМІ свою
місію як фотографа вин ващичу тому
щоб раз повістей про частку українських
біженців відкритий піф порожнього купити
осв-2 дано прогулянки вигаданих
переселенців в Україні то ще вина
завжди найбільше виражаючи на базах з
нижчих дітей
літніх людей хворих нині ті люди 1
поршень і по всій Україні
дільничної Росії і в них нам теж
давали символічно що вина на сході
україни буде науково приз у мене в офісі
інституту в момент лігу вид крутячи а gsm
це вина
багата в чому убити що втягнула німецьку
парламент
і рішення про створення інституту